you
it warm order vote
welcome not till then her press
conference and the risk of listen tiara
all its noble please if you see welcome
to this press conference where we will
present this year's Nobel Prize in
Physics as usual we will start in a
Swedish and then continue in English but
when we have the question time you are
of course free to pause the questions in
either language you're here the staff a
new market and the security at other
hair become Lea Vietnam scopes Academy
n-- Omiya may some sake anagha busy
today are three few seeker till her gir
city professor Yan Yan son would foreign
day in Nobel Committee and the physique
some cancer burger king comedians
pre-soviet
Welling Steven stromae how a professor
pedal Singh Leah the mood in the bell
committee emphasis oak nur must
professor on lily even Julieta mood in
Nobel Committee on physique or the
satvatas not folklore a prism eroded
Mary in corner all its physic please
Harlem vekselberg on melon use oak
materia camellia via telescopes Academy
in hoid on be saluted telephoto Santorum
or Nobel Prize a physique till professor
Rajesh
Arash read caleche de France okay Cole
normal superior Paris Frank Ricci orc
professor David Yi Vineland
with the National Institute of Standards
and Technology for University of
Colorado Boulder us all Academy is
motivating leader
Fairborn Britain the experimental Lama
to the Somali your maddening Oh stealing
of Ian Stoica grant system
this year's Nobel Prize in Physics is
about interaction between light and
matter the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences has decided to board the 2012
Nobel Prize in Physics to zur Sh
arash at caleche de France and Ecole
Normale superior Paris France and David
J Wineland at National Institute of
Standards and Technology and University
of Colorado Boulder we saw and the
Academy Citation runs for groundbreaking
experimental methods that enable
measuring and manipulation of individual
quantum systems professor beyond us will
now give us a short summary in English
please
thank you very much yes the world this
year seven horse and David won and they
work in a field offices called quantum
optics this is a very active research
field and it studied the fundamental
interactions between photons light
particles let's say and matter in fact
when we look at each other today here in
the room it's the interaction between
light and matter that makes us see each
other the Nobel Committee is especially
singing out the groundbreaking interact
inventions made by the lawyers that has
led to the possibility to measure and
control individual quantum systems this
is something physics has dreamt one
since dawn or quantum mechanics and
today it's a possibility
the method has in fact many things in
common there are two different methods
david wide line he traps charged atoms
we call them ions controlling in an
electric field and then he controlled
them and measure them with photons which
are the pockets of light Sarah rose on
the other hand takes the obvious
approach he controls and measures
trapped photons he trapped them between
two mirrors
and then he sends Adams true that threat
were it attracted the photons and these
atoms act as spies and give information
about the photons without destroying
them
this work had opened up a new era of
experimental possibilities they study
both basic questions like in quantum
physics like DLP the coherence and for
the daily life the realization of the
most precise clocks ever seen is a
reality with their work and this piece
price has also paid the first steps
towards future quantum computers that
was very computers with speeds that
would exceed everything and would be a
dream for every program thank you
professor Johnson now turn to Professor
pear Adele sting that will give us the
first part of a more detailed
presentation thank you so professor
haroche and his collaborators have been
able to capture light particles that
means photons and they've used atoms to
probe the state of the photons so how do
you capture light imagine yourself
standing in an elevator with two mirrors
if you hold up your finger you will
actually see many fingers in the mirror
that's because the photons are bouncing
back and forth between the mirrors
before they reach your eyes many times
so this so this means that you can
actually if you have two mirrors like
this you can actually capture light
between the mirrors and you can send in
atoms between the mirrors to control or
to to measure what the photons are doing
this is an idea that has been perfected
by Sir Charles group like this so they
they have done this for microwaves and
and this they can do this they can
actually
capture just a single photon and they
can also do it for a sufficiently long
time so that they have time to study the
photons in this cavity so one of the
things they've done is that they have
been able to detect photons without
destroying them this is actually very
hard to do for instance when I look at
the people in this room right now the
photons that reaches my eyes are
absorbed by my eyes and therefore
destroyed but it is actually possible to
detect photons without destroying them
if you take atoms specially prepared
atoms which are actually there are
usually large and they're also doughnut
shaped and send it into this cavity you
can interact with the photons that are
there and that will change the state of
the atom that comes out so by measuring
the atom when it comes out you can tell
whether there was a photon in the cavity
or not when you measured this is a
little bit like eating the cake and
having it to this technology has been
extended and and refined by social
Rush's group and they've done a number
of very important experiments based on
this technology so the quantum in the
quantum world particles can take on two
states at the same time but in our
ordinary world big things cannot so the
quantum world is clearly very different
from our ordinary world and the process
that that explains how a system loses
its quantum properties is called
decoherence and this is something that
Serge haroche has studied in detail some
80 years ago
Irvin Schrodinger proposed a thought
experiment to show how strange the
quantum world is and it involved a cat
that would be both dead and alive at the
same time this sounds very strange but
the point here is there
this type of experiment can now be done
in the laboratory in fact of both
laureates they can both produce states
which are like these Schrodinger cat
states and they can follow this in
detail quantitatively in time so the big
breakthrough was in in 1996 when Serge
Howard washers group managed to do this
for the first time decoherence is very
important because it allows us to
understand or our world which is
governed by quantum mechanics but still
it doesn't show these quantum properties
on the large scale Thank You professor
Dale Singh and now professor Anna Lilla
here will give us the second part of the
more detailed presentation please
so I'm going to describe the work of
living Weiland and his group so this is
about ions hi how do you capture an ions
ions are atoms in an electric charge so
to capture an eye on you you use
electrodes electric fields as is
represented here how do you observe ions
you use photons and more specifically
laser light to excite these atoms and
these atoms these ions decay by emitting
night so you look at the fluorescence
that is emitted by by these ions and
this shows this is a photograph of
actually not the ions themselves but the
light that is emitted by three beryllium
ions that are captured in the same trap
the VIN violent and his group have
achieved extraordinary control over the
states of an iron and iron can have
different internal states which means
that the electron can take different
energy levels they have been able to put
an ion into one state for example down
into the other state up or actually into
a superposition of these two states up
and down and an ion can also have
different motions they different
vibration States they can move one way
or they can move another way this is
indicated here as 0 1 or they can
actually and this is the magic of
quantum mechanics move into two
different ways at the same time and
whinin honey's group have shown that it
is possible to actually transfer a
superposition of internal state of an
ion to a superposition of motion state
of the onion why is it important this is
important in particular since it's the
first very tiny steps towards what is
called a quantum computer computer on
computer is a dream that many physicists
have to build a computer that does not
work with normal beats zero one as in a
classical computer but with quantum bits
this is the superposition of states and
it is predicted that quantum computers
can be much faster for certain type of
operation than classical computers but
it will take a little time before all of
the laptops that you have here in this
room will be replaced by a quantum
computer very important application of
one's work is optical clocks the
measuring of time how do you measure
time you need something that oscillates
like the tip in a metronome or this this
tip here in a very old clock this is
something that oscillates at TACC and
the more the oscillation you have the
more precise your clock be today's clock
is based on cesium atom that work in the
microwave range with the work
accomplished by one Anson hick workers
now we can use ion clock and ion clock
worse work in the visible it's called
optical branch with the possibility to
have 10,000 more oscillations to measure
time than with the cesium clock and with
this ion clock they have achieved a
precision which is as good as 10 to
minus 17 what does it mean that mean
that if such a clock had been existing
since the beginning of our universe like
14 billions years ago then this clock
would have gone wrong by at most 5
second with that I thank you for your
attention
Thank You professor Lee and just 30
minutes ago we got hold actually of both
laureates and we will now see if we have
one of them on the phone I think it is
Professor rush from Paris hello
professor rush
are you there
I think you I told you that we are
sitting here in the session hole at our
Academy in Stockholm and I hope you are
ready to hear my name is right now first
of all congratulations did you tell
anyone yet have you told anyone yet yes
in fact I called one of them was
lecturing and activator interrupt your
lecture and call me immediately
children again professor we have some
some problems to hear you probably some
technical problems but you know there's
a big party coming up are you coming to
Stockholm in December that have a great
day thank you thank you very much we
have a second question there hello i'm
corey boys from swedish daily dog
another big congratulations I have two
short questions first those quantum
computers when do you think they will
exist in reality and the second question
those very extremely excited clocks when
the can they what can they be used for
first question those quantum computers
well when will they exist in reality
when can we use those who are the
gravitational shift with very high
precision and so the clock could be used
to some irregularity in the
gravitational field to George Dickel
application for earthquake predictions
this is one kind of application all the
kind of application are we
for instance a lot of notices could be
expected from space stations using very
precise clocks we have a final question
yeah hi name is Josh and congratulations
to the prize my name is Louise I work
for The Associated Press I was wondering
did you see this coming
do you just consider myself as one one
of the positive choices but very well I
I just said that there are many people
who deserve the prize and the
probability for each of us to get it is
rather small so I tried to not to expect
too much and I was not really expecting
it and especially I was not expecting it
so much this year sorry it's really
surprised wonderful surprise and I am
also very very glad to share it with day
one because it's fantastic to the system
and a better judge other than yourself
and to be in his company is certainly a
great pleasure for me and the great
recognition thank you thank you very
much we've had some difficulties in in
hearing you I'm looking at the physicist
here and hopefully promised a quantum
quantum telephone next time so very high
resolution thank you very much
arash and once again warm
congratulations and we look forward to
see you here in Stockholm in December
for the Nobel Prize ceremony thank you
so do I have any questions from the from
from the press here to to our experts if
not I will close this press conference
and we shall welcome tomorrow where we
will announce the Nobel Prize in
Chemistry thank you very much